e
[Música]
ya sean estampados con lentejuelas o de
colores los calcetines se han convertido
en auténticos accesorios de moda
[Música]
en francia se venden 300 millones de
pares al año aunque los chinos tienen
prácticamente el monopolio del mercado
las pequeñas pymes francesas como curso
con sede en la región de lemos intentan
hacerse un hueco
[Música]
una apuesta arriesgada la del made in
friends
una marca de alta gama que obliga a la
pequeña empresa familiar a innovar
constantemente con diseños cada vez más
complejos
[Música]
no tendríamos esta calidad de dibujo ni
esta calidad de trabajo demuestra sólo
haríamos fue la producción no
existiríamos está claro
para realizar estos diseños este
empresario también eligió materias
primas más caras y de excelente calidad
se trata de algodones de egipcios o
indios teñidos en francia
así que aquí tenemos algodones de
alrededor de diez euros por kilo algunos
a dos euros por kilo en china se pueden
encontrar a uno o dos euros pero no con
esta calidad de todos modos aquí estamos
a casi veinticinco euros por kilo
incluso ha invertido en 17 máquinas
automáticas de última generación
esenciales para producir la malla más
fina posible aquí como pueden ver se
trata de medias muy muy finas con
costuras protestas con culturas finas
para que no estorben caminar las medias
muy finas
un producto cuya fabricación cuesta
cuatro euros veinte veces más que en
asia pero que ha convencido a un
centenar de minoristas franceses porque
desde hace unos años lo producido en
francia está de moda es sinónimo de
refinamiento y originalidad
ahora vamos a visitar a uno vamos a
vender medias ese es el objetivo del día
nos encontramos esa mañana en parís en
la tienda slip consell en 2012 la marca
inició una colaboración con la familia
russo para ofrecer además de calzones y
boxers su propia gama de calcetines
en las últimas semanas se han vendido
más cantidades de medias que de boxers
hoy en día los productos que más
vendemos son las medias negras y azul
marino
un par de medias cuesta entre 9 y 15
euros como puede uno justificar ese
precio es más caro 2 pero no me importa
invertir más dinero en un producto de
calidad con el tiempo si se conserva más
en última instancia no creo que sea
mucho más caro como marca no decimos no
comprende afuera no está bien comprenden
francia es lo correcto nos levantamos
como podemos hacer que la gente quiera
volver a curarnos y que quiera comprar
productos más duraderos que están hechos
por gente que trabaja que son co horas
que tiene vacaciones para las que tiene
seguida social y socialmente
la fábrica francesa ha sido el credo de
la empresa abuso desde sus inicios
todo comenzó en esta fábrica en 1938 en
aquel momento el abuelo de aymerich
curso consideró que las medias eran un
producto del futuro y pudo encontrar
hilo para fabricarlos
y creamos una fábrica de hilo cargado en
esa época y salíamos al campo de los
alrededores a comprarles lana a los
ganaderos ovinos fue con esta lana de la
región con la que empezamos a tejer
nuestras primeras medias el abuelo de
aymerich era un patrón a la antigua
vivía en este apartamento dentro de la
fábrica
y
creo que si no le hemos tocado si es una
de las pocas partes de la fábrica que no
hemos tumbado y la reconstruimos por
completo es sin duda porque es uno de
los espacios que obviamente me costó más
restaurar
el destino de la fábrica no ha sido
fácil en 2006 puso se declaró en
liquidación y luego reanudó su actividad
con sólo 40 empleados entre ellos esta
empleada que lleva más de 20 años
intentaron explicarnos que iban a
retomar una actividad para saber si
estaba disponible si quería volver y
entonces d se hizo así muy rápido
para volver a poner en marcha el negocio
familiar oso empezó a vender por
internet en 2008 al elegir colaborar con
la marca sirias la pyme pudo darse a
conocer en la web
cuando en mi vida en 2008 era complicado
combinar productos de calidad fabricados
en francia con un precio atractivo y
modelos de moda
así que para nosotros era esencial
hacerlo a través de la web porque estas
tiendas aún no estaban abiertas a esto
[Música]
el último golpe de la marca ha sido
seducir al cantante stromae fabricando
los calcetines que lleva en el escenario
la empresa puso sigue tejiendo los hilos
de su éxito